loin de l'agitation de la capitale et
l'adie lassouli veille sur ses tomates
ses pommes de terre et son verger sur
ses terres mises à disposition par le
gouvernement dans les années 80 le
départ de l'ex président bouteflika a
fait naître en lui un espoir de
changement pour l'algérie mais plus de
deux ans plus tard l'excitation est
laissé place à la déception sentiment
qu'il a poussé aujourd'hui à boycotter
les élections législatives anticipées
on l'a pas vu le changement et à cause
de ça je vais pas aller voter parce que
je ne crois pas à ces élections je crois
pas ce changement il ya 220 détenus
d'opinion c'est à dire si on veut
vraiment aller vers un pays démocratique
on emprisonne pas des gens pour leurs
opinions
on n'est pas arrivé à à concrétiser
notre idéal le rêve le rêve d'un
algérien qui qui vit dans une république
démocratique et populaire
nous on cherche réellement elle est où
la démocratie dans cette république
cette déception semble avoir gagné une
grande partie de la population
algérienne principalement chez celles
qui a choisi de l'exprimer dans la rue à
travers le mouvement du l'irak médecin à
la retraite
djamel eddine ou lan est devenu depuis
deux ans militants et activistes engagés
pendant plus de trente ans il a réalisé
pour le ministère algérien de la santé
mais aussi pour l' oms et l'onu des
campagnes de prévention
les affiches de sensibilisation d'antan
ont laissé place à de nouvelles beaucoup
plus engagé hostiles au gouvernement en
place il y à une répression terrible
c'est ces dernières semaines
plus de deux mille arrestations de
militants des activistes pacifiques des
gens qui n'ont rien fait d'illégal
c'était le fait seulement d'exprimer
pacifiquement leur opposition à la
feuille de route de ce pouvoir
il ya aussi l'aspect de des médias c'est
une certitude
c'est une honte ce qui se passe en ce
moment dans les médias qui sont
contrôlés par le pouvoir
dans ce climat je pense que ça serait
vraiment ignoble de notre part de
participer à ces élections un possible
boycott doublé d'un rejet de la
chose politique que le politologue
brahim zitouni explique par l'incapacité
de l'état algérien à opérer les réformes
nécessaires aux aspirations populaires
en réalité déception excès excitation
sont les deux faces d'une même pièce
c'est le renvoi à des explications
idéologique d'un mouvement social
en fait nous sommes dans un paradoxe un
mouvement social de cette puissance 13
millions 14 millions d'algériens dans
les rues toutes régions confondues amène
forcément à une extraordinaire
politisation du mouvement social et ce
n'est pas l'un vers ce donc il y a une
vraie conscience politique
mais il n'y a pas de tradition partizan
ont créé tout simplement parce que
trente ans d'un système autoritaire au
fait fuir les élites capables d'encadrer
les jeunes
le choix des 407 membres de l'assemblée
populaire nationale suscite
interrogations et incertitudes qu'ils
soient votants ou partisans du boycott
il appartient à nouveau aux algériens de
déterminer les contours de cette
nouvelle scène politique post bouteflika
loin de faire l'unanimité